ciao ragazzi e benvenuti alla prima puntata di dillo con un emoji
ormai siamo bombardati di emoji
perchè ci giriamo e ci sono emoji da tutte le parti
mandiamo emoji nei gruppi della famiglia
nei gruppi con le amiche
quando flirtiamo con un ragazzo
quindi ho detto perchè non fare una serie di video
dove andrò ad analizzare
appunto i significati più nascosti di queste nostre amiche emoji
in particolare il video di oggi vuole andare a studiare da vicino
quali sono le emoji
che non dovete mai inviare ad una ragazza
ecco ragazzi aprite bene le orecchie
queste sono le emoji che non ci dovete mai mandare
top, che cos'era quella voce?
siete pronti? 1,2,3 dillo con un emoji
alla numero 1 abbiamo lei
ecco...vi dirò un segreto, cari ragazzi in ascolto
se ci mandate un messaggio corto ci incazziamo
se invece di mandarci il messaggio corto ci mandate il pollice in su
avete chiuso!
e poi c'è il buongiorno, quel fantastico momento dove, noi aspettiamo un vostro messaggio
c'è qualcuno che se ne esce con un buon giorno, con il sole, che cosa mi vuoi dire?
che fuori c'è il sole? lo vedo...anche io, che io sono il tuo sole?
lo stai dicendo nel modo sbagliato..
che tu sei allegro? mah e quindi?
per me è no!
Ma c'è qualcosa peggio del sole
il buon giorno dato con la manina...lei
ciao buon giorno, eh..
e...poi ci sono i baci ecco se siamo fidanzati il bacio è di rito col cuore
se me lo mandi senza cuore, vuol dire che la nostra relazione sta subendo qualcosa di terribile dobbiamo parlarne..
ma se non siamo ancora fidanzati, questi sono i tre baci che proprio non ci dovete mandare.ma va io mando le bombe altro che
lo stitico.... ammazza te sei sprecato, potevi evitare di mandarmelo a sto punto
il fischio, mah mi stai fischiando per strada? che cosa mi rappresenta? stai soffiando?
e poi c'è il bacino con le gote rosse, che carino che dolce, cosa fai il timido?
e poi dopo due messaggi te ne esci con una di queste emoji
ma analizziamole insieme partiamo da lei...
sei un golosone? Hai la linguetta di fuori? che carino...vuoi un gelatino?
è l'unica cosa che avrai da me
oppure parliamo di lei, sei pazzerello vuoi fare fiesta? lingua di fuori occhiolino jeeee, spostati! ;(
oppure ancora peggio lei, che cos'è un cane? sei un cagnolino scodinzoli pure?
che carino, portami la pallina
ma a proposito di cani,  c'è anche lei, che cos'è bava quella?
vuoi la pizza hai fame?
quando si messaggia e si  flurta, capita di non riuscire a rispondere a un messaggio magari sto facendo altro...tesoro
se tu in quel preciso istante mi mandi una di queste emoji,
crei solo una cosa in me, ANSIAAA
e poi ci sono i ragazzi che si sentono molto, ghetto mood e ti mandano i messaggi weee zia, scialla oppure pugnetto
respect! ma cosa sono la tua sorella? la tua #### del ghetto, si si belo perchè tu no #####
e poi arriva quel momento, tu vai a ballare con le tue amiche
e il ragazzo con cui ti stai sentendo e frequentando si vuole assicurare che tu faccia la brava
e ci scrive questa frase che ci provoca sempre un po di nausea, "mi raccomando fai la brava
e la accompagna sempre da questa emoji, l'angioletto che carino.
di solito quelli che ti mandano questa frase e questa emoji non fanno ne i bravi e non sono nemmeno angioletti.
e poi arriva il momento della buonanotte, il momento più dolce e più tenero della giornata, dove noi aspettiamo tanto con ansia
questo messaggino e ci arriva questo
fai tanta nanna, oppure buona ninna, che cos'ho tre anni?
di solito accompagnato da questa emoji,
ho detto tutto, PER ME è NO!!
Eccoci arrivati alla fine della prima puntata, DILLO CON UN EMOJI;
spero tanto che vi sia piaciuto il video, vorrei che mi commentaste qua sotto, dicendomi qual'è l'emoji che proprio un ragazzo non vi deve mandare.
Se vi è piaciuto il video ricordatevi di mettere LIKE,  di iscrivervi al canale e ovviamente di seguirmi su tutti gli altri social.
facebook, instagram, snapchat, musically
allahu akbar XDXD
e niente saluta andonio